t'as pas une petite bague ouvrière juste
heureux c'est là qu'est ce que tu veux
je peux vous raconter maintien ça se
passe c'est le be1 billet de 5 euros
habillé de tibro et à 2 500 euros
il meurt il se retrouve là où tu regarde
toi ça le biais de sa 16e 5 euros à
saint pierre qui dit au bureau de saint
lô billet de 5 euros mais écoute toi tu
vaux paradis direct le bio 10 euros et
l'arrêt et les dix autos cibié dioro tu
vas direct paradis était le billet de
500 euros qui arrivent il dit et moi a
dit ott falloir l'enfer et dieu pourquoi
le biais de 5 euros une vielle aure où
ils vont parader moi je vais en enfer
ni parce que toi ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'a pas vu l église n y allez me donnes
tu chantal tu as compris non pas
vraiment mais j'arrive pas à tenir les
blagues c'était déjà la barre son nom va
pas tout de suite j'ai pas que j'avais
déjà vous pêchez pouvoir mais personne
n'a compris et à la réputation de
compagnie avec son double puis ça
devient je l'aï doublé mais alors car
peu de toi
perfecto est finalement le trader police
a alors atteint j'oubliais tu m'entends
bien
non elle reprend depuis le 30 mai au
doigt de chanteurs ces farines et
l'automne quant à l'accord reprend
depuis le début pour nos téléspectateurs
on est en direct
chantal ladesou la blague du tracteur
deuxième c'est parti pour les 7 à égal
et 1 ferrari a mûri il est d'ailleurs un
tracteur sur le dos de campagne
il paraît qu'un retraitement klaxons n'y
arrive pas d'oubli tracteurs en bon il y
arrive et puis après il s'est confié à
notre chevaux un geste fait son show le
fils double et puis fin les routes les
routes et la chance de partir à
s'engager dans la mare le prêteur face
d'une lutte âpre débat et après la
reprise sur une petite fille à écoute
selah sue petites filles d'aller à
l'école avec un grand bandage autour de
la tête
la petite fille elle arrive à les
connaître un grand bandage autour de la
tête
la maîtresse guillemets chloé seppois ce
bandage au débat parce que ce matin je
me suis fait piquer par une abeille sur
le feu mais t'as pas de maladie mentale
il ya des gens qui arrivent là merci je
vais vous dire reprend la passe que
chantal elle en train de faire un apéro
une petite fille qui est arrivé à
l'école avec un grand bandage autour de
la tête
la maîtresse a dit mais chloé c'est quoi
ce bandage que tu as autour de la tête
elle dépasserait madame ce matin je me
suis fait piquer par une abeille sur le
front et tu vois la mer une bonne piqûre
d'abeille
ça nécessite pas un grand bandage à
dinan le bandage c'est parce que qu'on
perde la tuer avec une pelle c'est très
court alors c'est chantal qui essaient
de se connecter sur zone et michel d
merci ça marche ça va